le château morange
influencé par les travaux du baron
haussmann à paris la municipalité de
saint denis crée vers 1850 une grande
promenade urbaine au sud de la ville le
long de ces nouveaux boulevards des
dionysiens fortune et construisent des
villas raffiné entouré de vastes jardins
et vergers
parmi eux jean baptiste prospère morange
est à l'origine de la plus imposante
d'entre elles le château morange livré
en 1861 maison d'habitation pendant un
siècle le château morange et transformé
en maison des jeunes et de la culture
dans les années 1960
autrefois situé dans laxe d'une longue
allée bordée de palmiers colonnes la
maison est construite sur ans aux
soubassements trois portiques dont le
dessin est identique à celui du musée
léon dierx et du château nous rater
précède les façades ouest nord et sud
rendant l'édifice plus majestueux
la toiture ap entrée plat dit toiture à
l'italienne est masqué par un atika
balustrade bâti entre 1853 1861 le
château morange est un exemple tardif
d'architecturé néoclassique courants
esthétiques qui perdure durant tout le
19e siècle à la réunion originaire du
vignoble bordelais morange a sans doute
puisé son inspiration dans les châteaux
néoclassique de sa campagne natale
monument historique depuis 2010 le
château morange devrait faire l'objet
d'importants travaux de rénovation
visant non seulement à lui redonner
toute sa splendeur mais aussi son rôle
moteur dans la vie culturelle du
quartier